Two girls have dropped out,
and we need to replace them and replace them fast.
Hello. Hello.
This video is for Riley and Rhonda only.
If you're not Riley or Rhonda,
you can just keep scrolling.
But I have a person that I think would be perfect for this.
Perfect for this.
This is my beautiful friend Devin.
She is in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
She's a wedding photographer.
She is literally one of the most joyful,
kind people you could ever meet.
I've been friends with her for several years now,
and one thing that I love about Devin
is that she's the friend that you wanna call
if you're going through something.
And she's always so encouraging,
so joyful. She has this incredible relationship with Jesus,
and
her love for the Lord just shines through in all of her relationships.
And I have seen her generosity and her kindness over and over again.
Not only is Devin a wedding photographer,
but she also does all different kinds of photography.
Last year, my husband and I went to Paris,
and she came with us along with my other friend, hope,
and we just had the best time.
I have traveled all over the place with this girl,
and I have seen really crazy things happen to us,
and her still have the most positive,
kind attitude about the things that are happening.
She's very authentic to who she is,
and anytime you leave from hanging out with her,
you just feel Lighter because of how much joy she has
that I believe comes from the Lord.
So, Riley and Rhonda,
I definitely think you should give her a shot.
And if you have any questions,
feel free to personally message me,
and I will give you all the information
you could possibly want on Devon.
But give her a chance.